what happened when you were on itv and
you said i think i might throw my hat in
the ring you almost looked as if you
were half-hearted about it giving it a
go and here you are
you're right it's been a remarkable week
um and the events in the last week have
been astonishing i think last week
when we really saw the collapse of the
government uh by the end of wednesday it
became inevitable and undeniable that
we would be entering into a search for a
new leader
i believe i'm the only authentic
brexiteer to continue the brexit
promises contained in our 2019 manifesto
to deliver on our pledges and
importantly i'm the only candidate
standing today
who is uh honest about the solution to
fixing illegal migration namely small
boats crossing the channel yeah and you
want to come out of the european
convention on human rights why do you
want to do it
well i've seen throughout my experience
i was embarrassed of specialising in
immigration law defending the home
office before i was an mp and as
attorney general i've seen firsthand
that we can't fix
the problem of illegal migration because
of human rights claims and because of an
interventionist
court
politicized
strasbourg which is intervening to
thwart our domestic policies as we saw
last month on the rwanda flight and i'm
afraid the only solution
to this problem and if you want to be
honest with the british people
on delivering on brexit or taking back
control over our borders is that we do
now need to leave the european
convention for treatment i've pledged
that and i challenge all my fellow
candidates to make that similar pledge
none of them have even jacob rees-mogg
thinks it's a bad idea
well jacob is a great man and a good
friend and we do disagree on certain
things uh so i don't think jacob
rees-mogg is the uh source of all things
to do with uh to do with law i've seen
first-hand i've been in i use him as an
example because he's so far right-wing
that you know quite a lot of people
can't even see him on the pitch and yet
he thinks it's just a step too far
well with respect to jacob i've seen
first hand as i say i've been in court
fighting these cases for several years
and i've seen what's happened with the
rwanda flight and the rwanda policy the
reality is that the policy is vulnerable
uh to claims based on human rights actor
or the european convention namely
article 3 claims and article 8 rights
and and we will simply not be able to uh
remove in significant numbers uh those
people coming across the channel
illegally in risky circumstances unless
we
eliminate those kinds of claims against
our actions and that's why we do need to
leave the european convention on human
rights one of the reasons people like
jacob rees-mogg are not supporting you
is because they feel that you are
splitting the vote on the right of the
party
between yourself liz trust potentially
can be bad enough as well and what will
happen is that rishi sunat will triumph
as a result do you hear that do you feel
that that's that you're doing that and
that your campaign while you have picked
up a lot of support to get to this stage
that in the end you'll have to fold
behind one of the other campaigns listen
we take one round at a time i'm fighting
to win i'm incredibly encouraged that
i've got so many colleagues backing me i
just had a hustings today with the one
nation caucus i think it went really
well and i was we were laughing and uh
joking and you know there's great
rapport with so many mps here and i'm
just really enjoying talking to people i
want to unite the party i'm in this to
win it and i urge all the colleagues to
get behind me why
why are tv debates so important
they're really important i'm glad skye
is hosting one on sunday i think they um
will uh showcase uh and allow scrutiny
of all of the candidates up close and
personal if you like what exactly have
they done what are they pledging and
really what will they do and i think
it's really important so the mps and our
members and the british people will have
a clear idea of who some of these people
are some of some of us are not
some of the candidates are not
necessarily well well known to the
members of the public and i think
there's two people
well i think i've been the attorney
general i think i'm not necessarily
as big a name as um some you know boris
johnson so i think actually tv debates
are really important for um bringing
putting a spotlight on uh on who some of
these people are which is really
important
you have not been in the front line
delivery department you've not run the
health service you not run schools after
the pandemic you've not been in the
treasury seeing that if you cut many
many taxes as you're proposing to do you
have to also cut spending and make
really difficult decisions why should
your colleagues and the members put that
trust in you
based on your experience so far well i
disagree with you that i'm not in the
front line actually as the attorney
general um i not only run a department
but i oversee the crime prosecution
service the serious fraud office and the
government legal department those are
agencies of law enforcement
and legal
services employing thousands of people
around the country and i've been
instrumental in uh turning around
performance when it comes to crime and
justice and the criminal justice
performance so i think that's uh i don't
think it's fair to say that i i don't
know what it is to be on the front line
of delivery in whitehall in a leadership
position and what i'd also say is that
the attorney general is actually one of
the most crucial members of government
the gravest and most serious decision
any prime minister will take is about
taking military action or
launching a lethal strike
and in that scenario it's the legal
advice provided by an attorney that is
crucial the legal basis the evidence to
justify action that may well put
lives at risk
that pressure is excruciating that's
what the attorney general lives with
and therefore the attorney general is
absolutely critical both of the most
important moments of government decision
making but in all also in every other
area of decision making the attorney
general's advice and support and
work is absolutely critical so i know
what that pressure is like i know the
gravity
of what it's like to be at the center of
government and that's why i think i'm
exceptionally experienced to be stepping
up to be prime minister